le point fort le gros gros gros gros
gros gros gros point fort de cette
montre ses sont ok ça fait quelques
jours que je vous parle de mondes
connectés que je vous parlais de mondes
connectés parce que ça m'intéresse pas
mal et que j'ai vu plein de trucs super
cool alors aujourd'hui on explique on a
la possibilité entre tester la galaxie
watch
la tique watch pro et là me 23 on va
donc faire un pouf pouf une vache qui
pisse dans un tonneau c'est rigolo mener
ces [ __ ] mais comme le roi et la
reine ne le veulent pas ça ne sera pas
pas toi je sais je triche pour une vache
qui pisse dans un tonneau c'est rigolo
mais c'est sa jolie comme le royal ne
veut pas ça ne sera pas toi aller
aujourd'hui hans fehr lactique watch pro
ne demandez pas dans quelle école j'ai
été pour faire des plumes tout faux si
mauvais je sais pas si c'est en tout cas
un très bon il peut vous faire
maintenant que cet écho aux pratiques
aux pros et je la trouve plutôt cool
le produit qui reste par la tête ne
bouge pas voilà ça doit les objectifs
nous expose les rencontrer lorsque
j'étais à berlin il ya quelques jours on
l'a présenté et j'ai trouvé vraiment
hyper séduisante live painting déjà vous
avez un écran oled qui est super beau
elle a pas mal de deux spécificités
donc ce que je vous propose tout de
suite c'est de l'ouvrir on va regarder
ce qu intérieure
je me la mettre aux poignets et ensuite
je l'utilisé et on en reparle d'ici
quelques jours chez couach au désolé
c'est très très sobre comme boîte mais
je trouve ça malgré tout assez joli ça
c'est la classe toute sa superbe au ses
contours alors serré quand on la voit
comme ça c'est assez masculin mais
malgré tout le bracelet cuir et hyper
qualitatif bon c'est une attache à ses
standards sur les montres ça fait pas
comme sur les certaines montres côté un
peu plastique là pour compte ça fait
vraiment montre premium je trouve ça
vraiment super beau les gros boutons sur
le côté c'est pareil ça marche super
bien alors moi j'ai pas un très très
gros poignet mais on va regarder ça dans
quelques instants
alors ensuite à l'intérieur de la boîte
qu'est ce qu'on a on a ici un câble pour
le recharger directement alors c'est pas
comme sur les apple watch de la recharge
à induction
vous mettez en face vous posez en plus
c'est aimanté absolument rien au plaisir
à l'intérieur on a de la doc
ça fait quelques jours que j'utilise
maintenant la ti punch pro la monte de
mode veille
j'ai bien tester déjà fait plein de
choses avec et je voulais franchement
vous donner mon retour parce que je suis
pour vraiment mais vraiment vraiment
vraiment agréablement satisfaits alors
les mondes connectés
j'ai moi à titre personnel une
applewhite series 2 déjà testé pas mal
de différentes monde connecté et celle
là un avantage qui est non négligeable
et qui la différencie vraiment du reste
des mondes que j'ai pu tester sa
particularité c'est que vous avez en
réalité deux écrans là ce que vous voyez
c'est l'écran lcd
c'est dieu f sdn basse consommation bon
c'est un petit peu technique ensuite
vous avez en dessous juste en dessous un
écran oled qui vous permettra de tenir
entre 2 à 5 heures d'autonomie
ça dépend bien évidemment de ce que vous
allez en faire voilà ça c'est cool
vous avez plein d'applications pour la
santé s'est dit ouvert aux usa c'est
cool
vous avez plein d'applications pour la
santé la fitness le sport le planning de
plextor les exercices tout ce que vous
voulez la traduction fava il ya pas mal
de petites choses qui sont super cool
vous avez bien évidemment le calcul de
votre pouls avec un capteur de rythme
cardiaque qui est directement intégré à
l'intérieur comme vous pouvez le
constater je suis en plein repos je suis
hyper cool à 86 nos repas minutes vous
avez aussi le nfc à l'intérieur pour le
paiement dématérialisé ça c'est pour
google paie il ya pas mal de petites
choses super cool vos programmes de
santé vauhallan votre chrono enfin bon
ça je vous le passez c'est une mode
connecté un peu classique de ce point de
vue là mais en tout cas elle fait
vraiment vraiment vraiment bien la faire
vous avez comme je le disais un écran de
4 cents par 400 pixels cdu 1,39 pouces
mais vraiment et là où elle très très
très forte c'est justement le fait
d'avoir ces deux écrans superposés
lorsque je veux passer en mode essentiel
je vais appuyer sur le bouton du bas je
la met en mode est essentielle
j'aurais lille le mode est essentielle
là elle va rester en mode essentiel et
unique membre essentiel c'est à dire que
j'ai plus du tout l écran oled fin et
puis si ça me déclenché le capteur de
rythme cardiaque qui continue quand même
à fonctionner ensuite pour en sortir il
faut appuyer pour le redémarrer ça va
vous redémarrez en gros tout le système
avec l'écran oled tic watch c'est la
tique watch pro et ça c'est vraiment le
gros gros gros gros
au point phare traitement vous avez donc
une autonomie qui va aller entre 2 à 5
jours avec le mode classique mais
lorsque vous le passé uniquement en mode
est essentielle pour économiser de la
batterie
vous avez comme l'indiquent les infos
purement essentiel mais vous pouvez
l'utiliser jusqu'à 30 jours parce que
vous avez une consommation qui est
extrêmement faible a noté qu'à
l'intérieur vous avez une batterie de
415 milliampères heures alors je vous
rassure le fait de l'avoir en voie d
essentielle
on voit très très très bien même en
plein soleil donc ça ça marche plutôt
bien
je vous le dire dessus vous avez l'heure
la date dont deux pas activités dans
l'intérêt direct
donc ça c'est plutôt cool sur le haut
vous avez un bouton on off
lorsque vous appuyez ça vous activez
amont parce que vous appuyez vous avez
accès ici à toutes vos applications et
si vous faites un appui long vous avez
google assistant qui arrive le bouton du
bassin bouton qui est complètement
personnalisable vous pouvez lui a signé
ce que vous voulez comme raccourci dans
toutes vos applications et lorsque vous
allez faire un appui long vous allez
passer en mode essentielle alors c'est
pouvoir démarrer les temps car ce que
vous voulez et même s'ils voyaient
personnaliser le bouton lorsque vous
êtes sur votre écran d'accueil vous
descendez vous avez si accès à vos
paramètres à vos notifications à
réglages de votre luminosité vous avez
ici tous les paramètres de la monte
navigation par gestes ça c'est plutôt
cool sceptiques santé et si j'ai la pop
jazz coup comme ça ça me permet de
descendre directement dans mon menu
et lorsque je le fais dans l'autre sens
eh ben ça va être la verse je vais
remonter tout simplement et lorsque je
veux sortir carrément du menu cela
secoue et ça revient au début c'est une
montée certifié il pèse 68 qui du coup
ne craint ni l'eau ni la poussière alors
évitez quand même d'aller trop vous
baigner avec surtout tout ce qui va être
au ca les eaux chlorées franchement
éviter ça risque quand même de vous
l'endommager à l'intérieur un gps
podomètre compteur de calories capteur
de fréquence cardiaque
elle tourne avec un qualcomm were 2100
512 mégaoctets de ram et 4 gigas de
stockage elle a du bluetooth 4.2 du wifi
du nfc ça je voulais déjà dit notre côté
sympa sans l'annoncer le bracelet c'est
à dire que vous avez un bracelet hybride
lorsque vous la regardez comme ça elle a
un aspect cuir c'est un bracelet
l'extérieur en cuir donc premium très
masculin très très masculin elle est un
petit peu épaisse donc forcément ça va
rajouter un peu le côté masculin mais à
l'intérieur c'est du silicone donc vous
êtes cuir
silicon bon ça fonctionne plutôt pas mal
au poignet s'adapte bien elle se ferme
assez facilement on n'est pas comme si
on les appelle watch avec les brassées
d'origine vous allez un petit peu vous
arracher les poils
là c'est assez confortable la fermeture
est complètement classique 6 de leur
prochain un truc à cette montre c'est le
fait qu'elle soit un petit peu épaisse
peut pas tout avoir non plus c'est pas
extrêmement graves se trouve par contre
très très élégante avec tout ce côté
métal et les boutons également ici ça
lui confère un côté qui est assez
classieux pour que ça c'est vraiment un
point qui est extrêmement positive et
vos applications qui sont invariables
typiquement salut cédric qui a commenté
ma photo merci beaucoup à toi
cédric prouve que nos boys a vraiment
très très bien réussi sa copie avec la
tique watch propos dans tout ça c'est
bien mais qu'en est il du prix alors si
vous voulez la tique watch pro il vous
en coûtera le prix de 249 euros 99
centimes c'est très précis au centime
près à qui s'adresse-t-elle très
clairement pour moi ça c'est mon traître
et masculine de par le design le point
fort le gros gros gros gros gros gros
gros point fort cette montre c'est son
autonomie qui est énorme
là où une apple ou à cheval se recharger
tous les jours là vous allez pouvoir la
garder entre 2 5 jours en switchant
justement entre l'affichage lcd et
l'affichage oled je trouve que l'idée
d'avoir superposés ses deux écrans c'est
vraiment hyper malin parce que lorsque
vous voulez uniquement regarder l'heure
vous n'avez pas besoin d'avoir accès à
un écran led mais lorsque vous avez
réellement besoin vous utilisez
uniquement avec l'écran oled pour
pouvoir utiliser vos applications du
coup vous allez consommer uniquement
quand vous en avez besoin et pas tout le
temps ça c'est un point qui est vraiment
très très très très positif à la
question faut-il acheter 7 qui quetsches
pro à qui tout cas peut-on acheter cette
hypothèse pro très clairement je vous
dis oui
moy a sorti un produit qui est vraiment
excellent l'autonomie est dingue en
termes d'utilité c'est très bien moi en
tout cas je suis convaincue vous de me
dire ce que vous en pensez comment vous
la trouvez cette mode veille 7e tic
watch pro alors je vous invite à faire
une chaussée à rester connectés parce
que on va parler encore de montres
connecter pour que c'est un sujet qui
est super intéressante mais on
s'approche tout doucement des fêtes de
fin d'année donc ça pourrait faire aussi
des idées de cadeaux on va la tester
d'ici quelques jours
la galaxie watch de samsung comme ça on
regardera aussi avec la sont les points
positifs les points négatifs
ça permettrait un petit peu de se faire
une idée dites moi vous en commentaire
ce que vous en pensez qu est ce que vous
pensez de cette tique watch pro de
mauvezin
est ce qu'elle peut vous séduire et
surtout qu'est ce que vous pensez l'idée
d'avoir ces deux écrans lcd et oled pour
moi ça c'est juste une super idée
c'est vraiment un truc qui peut pas au
final tout con et puis surtout ce qui
est très bien c'est qu'on a absolument
aucune déperdition de qualité parce
qu'on peut dire s'il ya un écran lcd un
écran oled dessous est ce qu'au final je
veux pas perdre un petit peu en qualité
sans mon écran oled
absolument pas c'est complètement
invisible on se rend pas compte qu'ils à
deux écrans c'est juste c'est juste
couleurs j'imagine que derrière il y à
peine un brevet déposé par votre vol en
tout cas je trouve ça vraiment bien
voilà j'attends vos commentaires vous
marquez tout ça quant à nous on se
retrouve très bientôt pour parler à deux
mondes connectés de panneaux de choses
il ya plein de produits en test d'ares
ya donc croyez moi on va faire plaisir
[Musique]